vous avez peut-être remarqué de nombreux
véhicules de secours aux abords de
l'aéroport de Tours ce vendredi ce lundi
après-midi un exercice de simulation
d'une tuerie de masse qui était
organisée un test grandeur nature pour
apprécier l'accordation des moyens de
secours et la gestion de crise Faustine
nous
[Musique]
la simulation a commencé de terroristes
viennent de pénétrer dans l'aéroport de
Tours et de tirer sur les voyageurs
cette fois-ci heureusement il ne s'agit
que d'un exercice arme factice cri
diffusé dans les haut-parleurs et faux
sang une scène de tuerie de masse
reconstituée avec une centaine
d'étudiants infirmiers et leur
formateurs dans le rôle des victimes je
suis une petite fille de 8 ans et je me
suis pris une balle dans le bras je suis
censée jouer une personne en urgence
absolue qui a une plaie du thorax une
fracture ouverte de la jambe je joue une
personne qui a un scalpes au niveau de
la tête qui s'est pris une balle lors de
l'asso et du coup on attend les secours
les secours eux ne connaissent pas le
scénario il réagissent comment
situations réelle mais sous les yeux
d'observateurs des représentants des
différents services venus repérer les
points à améliorer l'essentiel c'est
qu'il y ait vraiment une bonne
connaissance des process des uns et des
autres une bonne coordination pour
parvenir à très rapidement
neutraliser la menace et
secourir les victimes
[Musique]
tout le monde après je m'en vais une
fois les terroristes neutralisés par les
forces de l'ordre il faut prendre en
charge les victimes même si je t'aide
on essaie j'ai vraiment mal
les pompiers prennent le relais il faut
soigner une quarantaine de blessés dont
la moitié est en urgence absolue
intervention du Samu recueille des
témoignages et recensement des personnes
présentes certaines victimes sont aussi
envoyées jusqu'à un gymnase
réquisitionné par la mairie ou jusqu'à
l'hôpital Trousseau qui participe à
l'exercice une reconstitution quasi
réelle pour repérer les points faibles
cette mise en situation c'est plutôt
bien passée
il nous reste effectivement à travailler
la question du zonage puisque tout le
monde ne pourra pas accéder à l'ensemble
de l'espace et c'est un point important
puisque les secouristes intervenants ne
peuvent pas s'approcher tant qu'il y a
un risque pour leur vie
un prochain exercice de gestion de crise
devrait avoir lieu en septembre en
Indre-et-Loire il simulera une situation
d'inondation